deidra is working with a function that
contains the following points these are
the x values these are y values and they
ask us is this function linear or
non-linear
so linear functions the way to tell them
is for any
given change in x is the change in y
always going to be the same value for
example if when x when for any
one step change in x is the change in y
always going to be 3 is it always going
to be 5 if it's always going to be the
same value you're dealing with a linear
function if for each change in x so over
here x is always changing by 1. so since
x is always changing by 1 the change in
y's have to always be the same if
they're not then we're dealing with a
non-linear function we can actually show
that plotting out if the changes in x
were going by different values if this
went from one to two and then two to
four what you'd wanna do then is divide
the change in y by the change in x and
that should always be a constant in fact
let me write that down
linear
if it's if something is linear then the
change in y
change
in
y
over
the change in x
over the change in x
always constant
always
constant
now in this example the change in x's
are always 1 right we go from one to two
two to three three to four four to five
so in this example the change in x is
always going to be one
so in order for this function to be
linear our change in y needs to be
constant because we're just going to
take that and divide it by 1. so let's
see if our change in y is constant when
we go from 11 to 14 we go up by 3.
when we go from 14 to 19 we go up by 5.
so i already see that it is not constant
we didn't go up by three this time we
went up by five and here we go up by
seven
and here we're going up by nine so we're
actually going up by increasing amounts
so we're definitely dealing with a
non-linear function and we can see that
if we graph it out so let me draw i'll
do a rough graph here so let me make
that my vertical axis my y axis
and we go all the way up to 35 so i'll
just do
i'll just do 10
30 actually i could do a i could do a
little bit more granular than that
i could do
and then 35
and then our values go 1 through 5. so
i'll do it on this axis right here
they're not obviously at the exact same
scale so i'll do one
two
three
four
and five and so let's plot these points
so the first point is 1
11. when x is 1 y is 11. this is our x
axis when x is 1
y is 11. that's right about there when x
is 2 y is 14 when x is 2
y is 14 that's right about there
when x is 3 y is 19.
when x is 3 y is 19 right about there
when x is 4 y is 26 when x is 4 y is 26
right about there and then finally when
x is 5 y is 35 when x is 5
y is 35 right up there so you can
immediately see that this is not tracing
out a line if this was a linear if this
was a linear function then the all the
points would be on up would be on a line
that looks something like that that's
why it's called a linear function in
this case it's not it's non-linear it's
the rate of increase as x changes is
going up